away by that that is so cool of course
top gun is one of these summer
blockbusters coming into theaters in
fact tonight i'm hosting a screening uh
tonight for top gun maverick at the
newly remodeled brendan theaters over at
the palms now you're gonna love it i saw
it on monday you're gonna absolutely
love it can't wait and rocky actually
stopped by the theater this week to
check out what it has to offer movie and
entertainment lovers
i'm here at brendan theaters at the
palms just chilling with the owner
johnny b we've got doctor strange on the
screen right now just first and foremost
before we get to the movie lineup what
kind of screen are we looking at right
now well right now we're in the jbx
auditorium it's wall-to-wall screen it's
laser projectors and we have adobe atmos
sound system in here and the most
comfortable seats they recline all the
way back okay no he's right they are the
most comfortable seats okay this
experience is already wonderful
and i also heard you guys have the
largest imax theater in las vegas
i built it when i built the theater it's
five stories high and it is original
imax in 2001 so yeah you have to
experience
these movies coming out like top gun
jurassic park elvis in imax jbx
dolby atmos
all right well listen this weekend this
is the movie theater to be to see top
gun i know everyone's super excited
about that are you excited for top gun
it's been 26 months i am
excited excited of course i am and i
will be here okay and there's a lot
coming up with brendan theaters you guys
are doing you guys are remodeled already
but you're adding on what can we expect
uh we're doing an altar lounge
taboo brendan at the palms and um and
that's
that's in about five weeks okay all
right we'll be we'll be back for that
all right
thank you thank you so much johnny b
here at brendan theaters at the palms
really the coolest and most unique movie
experience you can have here in the city
i'll send it to you
yeah it really is it's an unbelievable
the imax is the best by far
everything all those fears incredible
and on top of all that they have
graffiti art in the hallways now that's
part of the renovation and it's
beautiful to look at the only thing that
was missing she didn't have milk does
with her right next time next time rocky
so i like the new movies coming out the
brandon theater remodel is a must-see
too we'll be right back
furniture